I guess to me the only other thing that
would make sense is they were working on
the PS5 before the series The X version
right but then once again like does that
really make sense because you don't see
other games having this issue where they
gotta delay the Xbox version because
they had to get the PlayStation version
out like to me it's got to be a
limitation issue and the only difference
between the two variables is the S the
only because it seemed like they got the
PlayStation 5 one running just fine
I guess the only question I have for you
is what do you say for people who say it
can't be this series that's because it's
coming to PC also and there's less
configurations worser than the series s
on PC and that it's still coming to
those platforms
well it's been in those platforms for a
while like they're they're making these
current ports right now and sure there's
different configurations on that but
have you ever tried to play a piece